ANDREW: Hi.
I'm Andrew, a product
manager at Google.
If you've ever built
Ajax applications,
you know that it can
be a tedious process
as you deal with browser quirks
and the speed of JavaScript,
not to mention coordinating
development as the team grows.
Google Web Toolkit's a
development tool chain
that's designed to
solve these problems,
making complex, high performance
web applications easy to build
and optimize.
To better understand Google
Web Toolkit, or GWT for short,
let's look at four steps
in the development cycle.
Write, debug, optimize, and run.
I'll do that using
the mail sample that's
included with the GWT SDK.
Let's go into Eclipse
and open up the project.
The GWT SDK provides a set of
core Java API's and widgets.
These allow me to write browser
based client applications--
in other words, Ajax
applications-- in Java,
and then compile the source in
the highly optimized JavaScript
that runs across all browsers.
Constructing complex web
applications is more productive
thanks to a higher
level of abstraction
on top of common Ajax
concepts like DOM manipulation
and XHR communication.
I'm not limited to
pre-canned widgets either.
Anything I can do with the
browsers DOM and JavaScript
can be done in GWT,
including interacting
with handwritten JavaScript.
With the latest
version of GWT, I
can construct my UI in a
template using UI Binder.
The constructor for
the male detail widget
used to be multiple
lines of object creation.
Now it's simply one line
with the UI laid out
in an accompanying XML file.
Currently, this application is
just client side JavaScript.
The Java source is located
in the client package.
At deploy time, those files
will be compiled into JavaScript
and run in my user's browser.
Usually I'd have
server code as well.
I don't have to use
Java on the server.
But if I did, I would
add a server package
and put my server side
Java source in here.
Files in that directory
will run its bytecode
in any server container
such as App Engine.
To communicate between
my JavaScript client
and the server, GWT provides
an optimized RPC mechanism.
So I don't have to worry
about low level HDTP calls.
Now, if my server was running
something other than Java,
I could just as easily use JSON.
With some code written, I can
debug in my favorite Java IDE,
just like I would a desktop
application, and also
in my favorite
browser, just like I
would with straight JavaScript.
The Google Web Toolkit
developer plugin
spans the gap
between Java bytecode
and Debugger and
JavaScript in the browser.
This has two benefits.
First, because we're
running Java bytecode,
it means I can debug as I
would any Java application,
setting breakpoints, inspecting
variables, and stepping
through code.
Second, I can develop using the
familiar edit, refresh, view
programming model of JavaScript,
seeing my Java source code
changes in the browser
without compiling.
Google Web Toolkit
contains two powerful tools
for optimization.
First, the GWT compiler
performs optimizations
across my code base--
in-lining methods,
removing dead code,
optimizing strings,
and many more things.
With some guidance
from me, the compiler
can also segment my code into
multiple JavaScript fragments,
splitting up large applications
for faster startup time.
No more animated
spinners as my user
waits for an app to download.
But bottlenecks aren't
limited to JavaScript.
Browser layout and CSS
often behave in strange ways
that are hard to diagnose.
Speech Tracer is a
new Chrome extension
in Google Web
Toolkit that allows
me to diagnose performance
problems in the browser.
After I've compiled the
application to JavaScript,
I go to Chrome, and I can
monitor its performance.
Among other things,
it will show me
what interactions are
slow on the sluggishness
graph and a drill down of
where the time is going.
Finally, I'm ready for users
to run the application.
I use the Google Web Toolkit SDK
to compile my client-side Java
code into optimized
standalone JavaScript,
the Java scripts contained
in this cache.html file here.
The compiled script
is heavily optimized.
But if I want to
inspect the output,
GWT provides a
pretty compile option
that will generate the script
in human readable form.
The compiler handles browser
implementation differences
for me and creates an
optimized file per browser.
Browser specific files mean user
downloads only what he needs.
For instance, an
Internet Explorer user
doesn't download code
needed on Firefox.
My application is now ready for
users to run on all browsers,
including mobile browsers
on Android and the iPhone.
With Google Web Toolkit,
I spend less time
worrying about browser
quirks and more time
writing fast web applications.
To learn more, visit
code.google.com/webtoolkit.